نتابع هذه الصور مشاهدينا من ولايه دارفور
حيث تنتشر المئات من قوات الشرطه
لمن عمليات النهب كانت قبل قليل مصادر
العربيه قد اكدت نهب سوق الجنينه غرب
دارفور ومستودعات ايضا كذلك للمنظمات
الانسانيه هذه صور كما نشاهد الان ثابته
من ولايه دارفور لانتشار المئات من قوات
الشرطه السودانيه والتي تنتشر لتامين هذه
الاسواق اسواق
يعني نياله ودارفور ايضا كذلك هذه العربات
اذا
وكذلك افراد من الشرطه
لتامين هذه الاسواق
خشيه نهبئه مره اخرى كما نهب سوق الجنينه
غربا دارفور وكذلك ايضا حتى المنظمات
الانسانيه كانت قبل قليل ايضا مصادر
العربيه قد اكدت بان هناك عمليه نزوح
وحركه كبيره من دارفور باتجاه تشاد ولا
زلنا نشاهد هذه الصور امامكم الان وهي صور
ثابته متداوله طبعا
للجيش او عفوا للشرطه السودانيه وهي تنتشر
وتنشر عناصرها ايضا في الدارفور منعا
لنهب هذه الاسواق نعم لمتابعه المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات